zdf heute live herzlich willkommen holen
sich die ukraine jetzt ihr land zurück
so wie es der ukrainische präsident sie
lenski in seiner neuen videobotschaft
angekündigt hat im süden haben
ukrainische truppen offenbar begonnen
die russischen besatzer mit einzelnen
angriffen zurückzudrängen aber ist das
jetzt die große erwartete gegenoffensive
das ist schwere angriffe in und um die
region und die stadt person gibt das
bestätigen beide seiten bilder davon
gibt es auch wenn es nicht viele sind
von verschiedenen offensiv aktionen ist
die rede darüber wie erfolgreich die
ukrainischen truppen aktuell sind
darüber gibt es aber keine belastbaren
berichte
wir sprechen über dieses thema heute in
der sendung schreibt uns wie immer gerne
euro und ihre fragen in die kommentare
oder wenn er oder sie die app nutzen als
hätte es heute - live im zdf de und der
der sie quasi alle beantworten kann den
könnt ihr schon sehen das ist dr gustav
gräßel experte für osteuropa militär
strategien und sicherheitspolitik beim
european council on council on foreign
relations schönen guten abend herr dr
gräßel schön dass ihr wieder mit dabei
sind und mahnt und die erste frage ist
natürlich die ob man von einer
großoffensive in diesem fall sprechen
kann würden sie das auch zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt als solche bezeichnen
großoffensive ist noch ein bisschen
verfrüht also ja zu einer großen
offensive
würdest du sagen gehören dass man direkt
auf aufbessern marschiert und dass man
kräfte massiert hat die den russischen
eindeutig überlegen wären dazu ist es
zumindest bis jetzt noch nicht gekommen
wir haben noch sehr intensive gefechte
donnersbach notice unter schweren
angriffen dass die weitere angriffe aus
dem kommt und jetzt heraus auf die vka
kriegs wieder ab da gibt es noch massive
russische puppen konzentrationen und die
ukraine können ihre mechanisierten
reserven aus dem bombast nicht raus
verlegen um sie irgendwo anders hin zu
werfen
dementsprechend ist das kräfteverhältnis
in carson
eigentlich nicht so dass es den ukrainer
erlauben würde am papier zumindest
die die russen rauszuwerfen oder
vollends zu schlagen das ja warum ich
sage auf dem papier es gab letzte woche
angriffe der russen die sich seit seit
august gegen brückenköpfe der ukraine
und gegen gewisse stellung in der
ukraine die auch gezeigt haben wie
schlecht die russischen truppen
eigentlich koordiniert sind und geführt
sind und hier die ukraine versuchen oder
haben versucht jetzt eigentlich am
montag
diese schlecht koordinierten drucken
normal auszutesten namen starke
aufklärungs trupps geschickt die man
testen wie gut diese kräfte eigentlich
eingesetzt sind und da scheinen sie
lücken gefunden haben beziehungsweise
schwache kräfte die man gut angreifen
kann und hier sind durchbrüche
entstanden die man jetzt versucht
auszunutzen wie weit das aber gehen kann
es jetzt die gute frage so lange dass
ein bewegungs gefecht ist haben die
ukraine immer noch gute chancen fehler
draußen auszusetzen die koreanischen
profitieren sind besser als die
russischen ihre führung ist flexibler
wenn es den russen aber gelingt mit
diesen kräften die sie haben linien in
der tiefe zu besetzen und dort statisch
wieder verteidigen zu können dann haben
die haben die russen im raum schon die
kräfte die sie die angriffe wieder
abzufangen und die einbrüche zu
begrenzen wir werden gleich mal
versuchen auch anhand von karten und ein
bisschen zu orientieren und dann können
wir noch mal genauer eingehen wo gerade
was passiert ich möchte gerne aber eine
allererste frage aus dem chat schon mal
bei ihnen unterbringen stefan es fragt
zum thema großoffensive könnten sie sich
bei der könnte es sich bei der
angekündigten ukrainische offensive um
eine finte handeln meiner meinung nach
lebt eine offensive vom
überraschungseffekt
also bei der ankündigung sozusagen das
die große große offensive jetzt kommt
das war sicherlich eine finte das hat
die russen dazu veranlasst stärkere
kräfte in den süden zu verlegen
massive auszusöhnen und das war auch
meiner ansicht nach das hauptziel der
ukraine weil man ja mit dieser geballten
angriff grafendorf schwieriger fertig
wird bei dem bei der bei dem jetzigen
angriff da gibt es schon dort berichtet
das ist vorstöße gibt der räume nach
russische berichterstatter ein das ist
russisch das ukrainische einbrüche die
russischen linien gegeben hat das
gewisse bataillone der russen wirklich
aufgerieben wurden also das zeigt schon
dass hier ein angriff vorgetragen wurde
der also schon mehr als eine finte ist
nur wie gesagt ob das jetzt auf person
selber geht oder ob man hier nur
begrenzt russische kräfte ins ziel im
leben schlecht sind die schwach sind die
in der vergangenheit schon nicht sehr
gut gekämpft haben das lässt sich nicht
abschließend
beurteilen ich glaube es ist eher
zweiteres ich glaube hier hin beugt man
die russischen linien etwas ein und wie
weit man kommt wird man sehen ein
angriff der eine wende bringen soll wir
hören kurz den ukrainischen präsidenten
der mit starken worten versucht hier das
blatt zu wenden
die ukraine holt sich ihr land zurück
die besitzer sollen wissen wir werden
sie bis an die grenze jagen an unsere
grenze deren verlauf hat sich nicht
geändert die invasoren wissen das genau
wenn sie überleben wollen ist es für das
russische militär an der zeit zu fliehen
gehen sie nach hause
die formulierung das blatt zu wenden die
ich da gerade gewählte war ja eigentlich
falsch denn man kann ja nicht sagen dass
die russen sehr erfolgreich wehren bei
ihrem bisherigen angriffskrieg aber
natürlich ist es das was sie lenski
damit bezweckt zu versuchen die
russischen druck truppen zurückzudrängen
auf russisches gebiet wie erfolgreich
wird das seien
ja wie gesagt dass es schwer ist schwer
zu beurteilen weil es auch von einem
guten portion glück abhängt
beziehungsweise von entscheidungen vor
die von lokalen kommandanten getroffen
werden auch jetzt die ukraine
erfolgreicher sind oder nicht aber
natürlich auch für die lenski warum er
jetzt natürlich auch an kündigt dass man
sich das land zurückholen will da geht
es natürlich politisch auch in viele
kassen ist eine hauptstadt eines großen
oblast
denen die russen annektieren wollen das
heißt gibt vorbereitungen für ein
referendum ist die vorbereitungen für
einen aktions beschluss das heißt dieser
dieser oblast zumindest in der
russischen absicht in die russische
föderation eingegliedert werden und das
zu verhindern ist
natürlich auch teile jetzt der der
ukrainischen kriegsführung die die
schläge gegen die versorgungslinien der
russen machen das leben dort schwieriger
und wir wissen auch dass sich der chef
der der russischen verwaltung der
militärverwaltung schon nach russland
abgesetzt hat also auch die politische
verunsicherung auf der russischen seite
ist enorm ja und das verzögert zumindest
wenn es den ukrainern gelingt es uns
einzunehmen dann vereint das auch aber
so verzögerte es zumindest diese
annexion pläne und diese vorbereitungen
für ein referendum weil man natürlich
unter den gegebenen bedingungen
nicht einmal den schein eines
referendums werde aufrechterhalten
können wir werfen mal einen blick in die
region wir haben eine karte vorbereitet
da können wir sehen wie die
frontverläufe sind oder wie der
frontverlauf ist im süden der ukraine
und wir sehen auch die stadt herrschen
dort im süden wir sind genau die stadt
wir sehen den micro den fluss der etwas
südöstlich des frontverlauf es dort zu
sehen ist was können sie aus ihren
informationen sagen wie dort im moment
die kräfteverhältnisse sind
also die demokratischen kräfte dort
bestehen in erster linie aus
leichter infanterie was sozusagen das
problem der ukraine ist weil diese
leichter in verdreht dass da alles offen
als flaches gelände tut sich natürlich
die tussi natürlich schwer angriffe
vorzutragen so lange wir noch nicht im
bebauten gebiets l weiß
es geht auch mindestens drei maskierte
privaten eine panzerbrigade und
zumindest ein nach unabhängiges
panzerbataillon dass auch in diesem raum
verlegt wurde
beziehungsweise da präsent ist dass es
zumindest eine eine reserve um mögliche
angriffe der der russischen seite
abzufangen und nach den erfolglosen
angriffen der letzten wochen dürfte
diese reserve vorgetragen worden seien
und jetzt angriffe zu führen die russen
hier auch weiter zurück zu werfen auf
der russischen seite
haben wir etwa 20 bis 30 bataillons
kampfgruppen in diesem raum stationiert
wo wir an das ja vorsichtig sein muss
die russische nation kampfgruppen sind
vor allen dingen im bereich infanterie
sehr unter der normalen stärke haben mit
starken verlusten mit abgängen auch zu
kämpfen gehabt dh die die kräfte sind so
pi mal daumen in etwa gleich die ukraine
haben mehr soldaten in der region dafür
haben die russen mehr schwere systeme
panzer artillerie mehr feuerkraft das
hält sich in etwa die waage da würde ich
gerne zwei fragen gleich loswerden
eduard kunst fragt über youtube liege
ich mit dem gedanken falsch aber herr
sommers dicht bebautes gelände da wird
feuerkraft eher zweitrangig sein und
gleich anschließend uwe jacobs fragt
auch über youtube wie viele verluste auf
beiden seiten mit wie vielen verlusten
ist dazurechnen bei so einer offensive
also die zweite frage ist natürlich ganz
schwer zu beantworten wie gesagt dahin
seien viel von taktischen entscheidungen
ab die ukraine versuchen ja die russen
dort zu packen wo es leichter fall in
der flanke man hat in den ersten großen
einbruch etwa bei einem regiment gemacht
einem einem von metzger regiment wo
viele zwangsrekrutiert soldaten ihnen
dass leute die internetkäufer blast
zwangsverpflichtet wurden sind die die
die haben sozusagen
nicht sehr motiviert verteidigt und da
gelangen ein buch dann das benachbarte
russischer fallschirmjäger bataillon
gleich mitgenommen hat weil die aus der
flanke dann überraschenden angriff
bekommen haben
solche manöver wo man es geschickt in
die flanke manövriert dir sparen
natürlich der ukraine etwa große
verluste die man sonst im rahmen eines
brutalen angriffs gehabt hätte
ja wenn man die stadt erreicht dann ist
natürlich die feuerkraft zweitrangig
dann könnten die ukraine ihre
überlegenheit an leichter in von trikots
spielen dazu muss man aber an care
sondern auch mal ran kommen zurzeit sind
die ukraine etwa etwa zehn kilometer von
person entfernt das ist offenes gelände
das sind brettl ebene felder und da
brauche ich dann natürlich kampfpanzer
oder brauche ich schützenpanzer um also
die kampfpanzer um direkte feuer
unterstützung zu leisten und
schützenpanzer um einbrüche zu erzielen
um diese freien flächen schnell zu
überwinden und dann eben die infanterie
er schnell in die ortschaft zu bringen
und das ist das ist so ein bisschen das
problem der ukraine weil die
mechanisierte transport also
schützenpanzer mannschafts
transportpanzer etc knappes gut sind
und kampfpanzer
hier sind vor allen dingen aus polen
gelieferte kampfpanzer jetzt im einsatz
diese kampfpanzer lieferungen haben etwa
die kriegsverluste der ukraine bis jetzt
ausgeglichen aber man hat natürlich
jetzt im vergleich zu den zu den russen
auch nicht auch nicht
unendlich viele reserve vor allen dingen
weil die wichtigsten klinischen
fabrikaten immer noch in dombach stehen
und dort in schwere gefechte vor
besitzen ganz kurze frage weil sie es
gerade angesprochen dann bevor wir uns
dann auch nochmal den fluss und die die
rolle der brücken auch angucken die für
die nachschubwege wichtig sind ganz kurz
stefan es fragt frage herr graf wie
geht's eigentlich unseren
panzerhaubitzen sind die noch vollzählig
also einiges sind sind in reparatur die
panzer bis 2003 nicht im kern oblast
eingesetzt das heißt
die geräte die im einsatz sind die sind
dort
die wechseln sich in dieser rolle
artillerie schläge in die russische
tiefe zu stehen beziehungsweise gegen
feuer zu geben mit dem system 27 ab das
ist ein
[Musik]
20,3 cm geschützt russischer bauart dass
eine ähnliche reichweite hat die
panzerhaubitze 2000 die übernehmen so zu
sagen wenn die panzerhaubitze 2000 nicht
im nicht einsatzfähig ist diese diese
spezielle rolle dazu muss man sagen die
panzerhaubitze 2000 habe das war heute
auch mit milo kritischen kollegen
gesprochen das passieren verschleiß
erlebt hat wer jetzt für das system
nicht ungewöhnlich es ist ja
ein system das sehr leistungsfähiges das
mit mit sozusagen eben sehr große
reichweite hat ein langes rohr aber auch
natürlich dann einen hohen gasdruck
einer kanone
der hohe verschleiß bei ständigen
gebrauch der ist dementsprechend da und
man hat dann man hat dann eine abnutzung
dieser geräte die werden aber die
kriegen neue ware die man an reingebaut
verschluss muss auch das aus
unter anführungszeichen in den service
das ist aber im rahmen dessen was auch
die die ukrainische atelier so gerade
die 27 die sind auch nicht genannter
fand die haben auch ihre ihren wechsel
betrieb erleidet weil eben diese
geschützter die diese hohe
leistungsfähigkeit haben die
verschleißen schneller die kurzhaarige
geschütze die die mit geringerer ladung
fahren gern rohre verschleiß und nicht
so schnell aber die haben mir auch nicht
gereicht
die die können nicht so weit vorher
unterstützung leisten
ja da muss jeder der so ein waffensystem
design der muss sozusagen trade offs
machen zwischen oder kompromisse finden
zwischen leistungsfähigkeit und
durchhaltefähigkeit und bei der
panzerhaubitze 2000 dies auf
leistungsfähigkeit getrimmt
die werkstatt an der stelle ein kurzes
kompliment von einem user namens raum
der schreibt gräßel informiert und
erklärt super das möchte ich ihnen nicht
vorenthalten und jetzt hören wir uns die
ukrainische armee sprecherin natalia
humyo kann die zur militärischen
situation in der region person was zur
einschätzung beizutragen hat
die brücken die als hauptverkehrsadern
über den fluss metro gelten sind durch
die ukrainischen an für unbrauchbar
geworden deshalb versucht russland
alternative übergänge einzurichten im
moment können sie keine verstärkung vom
linken ufer des nitro zum rechten
flussufer schicken
wie wichtig sind diese brücken diese
brücken sind enorm wichtig weil wir
haben schon gehört es kann keine
reserven über diese über den apple
verschifft werden und dasselbe gilt auch
für die munition der munitions verkauf
vor allen dingen artillerie ist
natürlich dann bei so schweren kampf
tagen wenn man sperrfeuer gegen
ukrainische angriffe schießen muss auf
der russischen seite nur hoch und die
munition muss ja irgendwo herkommen die
ukraine haben das haben wir auch in der
letzten nacht erlebt wie der
munitionsdepots angegriffen haben einen
bahnhof in der nähe angegriffen
verteilungs national für munition
angegriffen also da ist auch viel
munition jetzt in die luft geflogen und
teil der durchhaltefähigkeit der
russischen verteidigungslinien ist auch
die frage kriegt man neue artillerie
munition vom
ostufer des apple- oder vom südufer in
diesem fall dann an das nordufer heran
also die die verbindungslinien laufen ja
über die creme und dann dann über die
eisenbahn richtung karsau und da ist ein
großes fragezeichen natürlich jetzt wo
die brücken schwer beschädigt sind
reparaturarbeiten auch das weiteren
artilleriegeschoss unterbunden wurden
und vor allen dingen auch zumindest eine
dieser
behelfsmäßig eingerichteten ponton
fähren die noch über den fluss fahren
auch getroffen wurde
russland vor allem im verlauf dieser
woche oder auch der nächsten woche die
die munition bereitstellen wird können
um da einfach weiter auf hohem niveau
verteidigen zu können dass ein großes
fragezeichen
wenn hier die die russischen verteidiger
dann auf dem trockenen sitzen was die
munition angeht dann wird es natürlich
bitter dann hilft ihnen das die die
zahlenmäßige überlegenheit an geschützen
und panzern auch nichts mehr weil die
brauchen nämlich munition zum schießen
hier sind zwei kommentare noch auch zur
versorgung im ort gefragt über youtube
oder seine 1 wenn die infos stimmen die
ich so gelesen habe dann sollen die
russen an der südost front wohl derzeit
personal und lieferprobleme haben person
selber könnten im beisein über den fluss
wird es schwer ist seine einschätzung
und ein user namens thinq wave schreibt
welchen einfluss hat die schlechte
versorgung der russischen soldaten auf
eine mögliche offensive der ukraine
also wie gesagt die die auswirkungen auf
eine offensive der ukraine vor allen
dingen jetzt am
stehtisch westufer von kerner hat mir
kann sie erhebliche auswirkungen haben
die
ist natürlich jetzt schwer zu wirklich
nachzuvollziehen wie viel der dort
gelagerte munition jetzt in den letzten
schlägen dies ja auch nicht auf
ukrainischer seite intensiviert haben
vernichtet worden sind aber sind es
ist ein reparatur depot und mindestens
drei munitionsdepots in den letzten 24
stunden in die luft geflogen also das
ist
das ist auch schon mal was und es kommt
eigentlich und ob
auf artillerie schläge die in den
letzten wochen schon vorbereitet worden
sind eben ganz bewusst gegen
logistikdrehscheibe
was einen einen ukrainischen vorstoß
über den teer angeht da stimme ich dem
user vollkommen zu dass es nicht
wahrscheinlich die russen haben ja auch
schon seit längerem die brücken über den
nil zu sprengung vorbereitet das sollte
ein ukrainischer durchstoß erfolgen dass
man sie dann amt mehr aufhält das glaube
ich auch nicht dass das ukrainische ziel
ist dass man dann auch über den fluss
weiter hinaus stößt man muss bedenken
die
wenn die brücken gesprengt werden der
fluss ist sehr breit ist ja groß wären
sehr leicht verteidigt bahre
frontlinie man würde sich dann fünf bis
sieben regatten einsparen in der auf der
ukrainischen seite die man dann eben in
den in den don was vorlegen können teil
um dort eben auch das kräfteverhältnis
zu klinischen gunsten zu wenden bis
mindestens den den zwischen angriffen
etwas mehr entgegensetzen kann das ist
jetzt keine unerhebliche kräfteansatz
und darauf spielt natürlich auch eine
aus militärischer sicht eine ukrainische
offensive in carson an
und
wenn weiter in den süden oder wenn die
ukraine
etwa im herbst oder winter dann weiter
in den süden vorstoßen wollten dann
würde das aus dem raum sapporo ja auch
für sie ganz gut gehen herr kritzelt wir
sprechen gleich weiter hier sind
unzählige kommentare die kriege ich gar
nicht alle unter wofür ich mich jetzt
schon entschuldigen will wir kommen aber
gleich wieder zu ihnen zurück und dann
versuche ich so viel wie möglich weiter
zu geben wir wollen aber ganz kurz ein
blick in die ukraine selbst werfen dort
ist nämlich mein kollege herr hebestreit
er beobachtet vor ort die lage hat auch
seine einschätzungen vor ort spricht
dort mit den menschen hannah was weißt
du über die lage im südosten des landes
das ist eine sehr gute frage also wir
sind hier natürlich auch im mittelpunkt
dieses informations krieges gehören was
soll uns gesagt wir hören was die russen
sagen wir können selber nicht wirklich
beurteilen wo jetzt die front verläuft
so fern war das gespräch auch gerade ich
habe die ganze zeit hier mit gehört für
mich auch sehr interessant weil wir
natürlich auch immer irgendwie so uns
eine meinung aus dem was wir lesen aus
dem was wir hören in dem zusammenhang
würde ich gerne mal eine frage von ihren
herrn gräßel stellen wir hören immer
dass die nachschublinien der russen an
das westliche ufer des nitro zerstört
oder bedroht worden sind dann hat sie
lenski ja gesagt die russen mögen
verschwinden kommen die dann über diese
beschädigten kaputten brücken überhaupt
zurück oder sind die da jetzt sämtliche
aggressionen oder aktionen der
ukrainischen seite ausgeliefert und wie
muss man sich das vorstellen ich habe
dazu auch eine frage nämlich in die
regie und zwar an unseren
regisseur rüdiger kann kann er gräßel
direkt die frage von händler aus der
ukraine beantworten geht das technisch
ich höre gerade dass das nicht möglich
ist doch da ist es herr dressel sie
können direkt antworten
ja so die die die brücken sind für
fahrzeuge unbenutzbar weil sie eben
durch artillerie treffer soweit
bautechnisch unsicher sind dass man da
nicht mehr drüber fahren kann
soldaten könnten natürlich zu fuß schon
drüber laufen wenn es die sich absetzen
wollen wenn sie fliehen wollen es gibt
auch die nova hardcover da gibt es dann
einen staudamm auch über die staumauer
kann man sich zu fuß absetzen allerdings
die autobrücke die auch über den
staudamm läuft und die ist schon soweit
beschädigt dass man sie nicht mehr
befahren kann das gibt es einen
fährbetrieb der mit betonbrücken
eingerichtet ist wir haben natürlich
nicht die kapazität der autor brücken
und auch hier mindestens eine fähre
wurde schon durch die ukraine getroffen
das heißt auch er wird natürlich durch
den ständigen beschuss
behindert und das
sozusagen wird dann dieser engpass das
so sagen sollte die ukrainische
offensive erfolg haben und man hier
zudem drücken vor schluss dann werden
natürlich wäre natürlich die russischen
kräfte
eingekesselt dann wären müssten sie vor
allem in ihr schweres gerät zurück
lassen und das wäre natürlich für die
ukraine besonders hilfreich weil man
dann natürlich auch dieses gerät wieder
in stand setzen kann selber verwenden
kann etc aber man soll den tag nicht vor
dem abend loben also so weit sind wir
noch nicht und wie gesagt wir wissen
nicht wie geordnet der russische der
russische rückzug erfolgt ob man es gibt
ja mehrere vorbereitete die linien um
umkehr song wie geordnet man sich in
diese linien absetzen kann und oder ob
man hier auch wieder eine lücke offen
lässt die ukraine nutzen können deshalb
würde ich zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt
noch nicht zu viel versprechen was diese
offensive alles liefern könnte dann ist
es soweit sind wir
die ich noch nicht
vielen dank herr gräßel für diese
einschätzungen und dann gehen wir damit
wieder zurück in die ukraine zu häner
dessen frage damit hoffentlich
beantwortet ist hannah m darüber hinaus
was hörst du
also wir sind hier an dem einzigen
übergang von der russisch besetzten zone
in das ukrainische sogenannte freie
gebiet das freie gebiet das nicht
gesetzt worden ist da gibt es am tag
mehrere möglichkeiten für leute die die
russisch besetzte zone verlassen wollen
dahin zu gehen wir haben dort gedreht
und haben dort auch leute aus saison
getroffen die uns auch gesagt haben sie
haben dort lange ausgehalten aber jetzt
würden sie es nicht mehr aushalten sie
wollten dort weg das war noch kurz bevor
diese diese offensive oder
militäroperationen offensiven zuschnitt
ist wie man das noch mal bezeichnen
möchte losgegangen ist aber die für die
wäre das natürlich eine gute nachricht
dann doch wieder wir hatten da eine frau
getroffen die erzählt und sie haben
sogar ihre winterklamotten mitgenommen
weil sie davon ausgehen dass sie hier
unter uns ab dem jahreswechsel dann doch
verbringen müssen wir solche leute ist
es natürlich gute nachricht wenn eine
hoffnung bestehen könnte dass sie
zurückkommt und wir hatten letzte woche
den ukrainischen nationalfeiertag rund
um den wir uns mit vielen leuten
unterhalten haben und sie sagten
eigentlich alle eine aufgabe jetzt komme
überhaupt nicht infrage man habe schon
so viele opfer gebracht damaliger stand
waren etwa 9000 getötete ukrainische
soldaten das waren jedenfalls die
offiziellen zahlen dass man jetzt nicht
einfach aufgeben möchte und hoffte dass
man die russischen truppen tatsächlich
aus dem landwirt hinaus treiben können
für diese leute ist das natürlich jetzt
eine sehr sehr froh eine sehr gute
nachricht und wir haben das mitbekommen
als die ersten nachrichten kamen dass
davon eine offensive gegen offensive
gesprochen wurde wir hatten ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen mit
ukrainischem hintergrund und bei dem
siebten in einer tour die handys und die
waren natürlich sehr aufgeregt dass es
aus deren sicht jetzt gute nachrichten
geben würde hannah eine frage noch an
dich weil das hier wahnsinnig viele
leute in den chats auch bewegt nämlich
die frage nach den bevorstehenden winter
unabhängig von den militärischen
bedingungen die dann herrschen merkst du
wenn du mit den leuten spricht dass da
eine angst vor dem winter zu spüren ist
das ist eine sehr gute frage hier ist
der winter wirklich noch sehr weit weg
wir haben hier heute temperaturen von 35
grad gehabt und auch jetzt ist es noch
so wie das ist keine laue sommernacht
mehr dass sie schon so tropennacht
insofern beschäftigt der winter die
leute jetzt hier in dieser gegend nicht
so wahnsinnig aber natürlich es gibt
viele leute die sorge davor haben dass
vielleicht auch die unterstützung aus
europa zurück gehen könnte wenn der
winter dazu führt dass man in
deutschland sei es in anderen staaten
die unterstützung dann tatsächlich auch
spürt die man den ukrainern liefert weil
es eben dann kalt wird oder dergleichen
mehr das mit verschiedenen szenarien
denkbar und da ist hier die sorge schon
groß dass die unterstützung des westens
dann auf eine eine eine harte probe
gestellt werden könnte vielen dank herr
hebestreit für diese einschätzungen in
die ukraine dankeschön und damit gehen
wir wieder zurück zu herrn gräßel und
damit auch zur militärischen
einschätzung was der bevorstehende
winter denn für die ukrainische truppen
vor allem bedeutet
ja also die militärische logik liegt
eigentlich
sozusagen mit einer gewissen hoffnung
auf den winter zwar das hängt mit der
mit der personalentwicklung russland
zusammen diese russische spezielle
militär operation muss sie dort nennt
die stützt sich ja auch freiwillig als
auch leute die einen einen vertrag mit
der russischen armee
unterzeichnen und dann für eine gewisse
zeit dienen
wehrpflichtige wurden nicht in großer
zahl in diesen krieg geschickt bei den
meisten wehrpflichtigen die wurden
sozusagen überlistet oder zwang ausgeübt
solche verträge zu unterschreiben und
dann wurden sie noch während ihres
wehrpflicht dorthin geschickt aber das
ist eher die ausnahme als die regel
jetzt weiß man wann etwa diese diese
verträge unterschrieben wurden die
gelten entwürfe ein jahr nach der
ungenannten beide hatten viele
patriotische veranstaltungen genutzt um
leute für sechs monats verträge
anzuwerben sie würden also im november
auslaufen auch im
september oktober würden viele verträge
auslaufen ist es noch nicht ganz klar ob
russland die vollständig ersetzen wird
können durch neue freiwillige viele
rekrutierungsmaßnahmen etwa den
besetzten gebieten das sind ja einmal
geschichten
die sozusagen dann jetzt gibt es ja kaum
mehr männliche personen
da kann man nicht viele leute raus
pressen und sollte sich putin so
entschieden die leute durch zwang im
krieg zu halten dann ist davon
auszugehen dass ihre moral sinken wird
dann leute die sozusagen über das was
die zugesagt haben im militär bleiben
müssen die das haben wir im märz april
schon gesehen als eine ähnliche
situation eingetreten ist die sind oft
nicht sehr motiviert dann kommt es zu
fällen von befehlsverweigerung zum teil
auch von weiteren et cetera also das ist
etwas was dann auch auf die kampfmoral
drücken würde und das stimmt auf der
anderen seite viele ukraine wenn es etwa
in großbritannien trainiert es gibt
verhandlungen immer nur neue
waffensysteme also hier die ukrainische
armee
wird stärker die generalmobilmachung ist
ja abgeschlossen man trainiert die neuen
einheiten die wir noch kampf verfahren
mit der zeit das heißt hier sieht man
sich sozusagen anwachsen während dagegen
hat personalprobleme hat das haar und da
da gibt es viele rechnungen das in etwa
im winter diese schere dann irgendwann
für die russen zu gehen könnte dass wenn
sie nicht mobil machen anordnen oder
wenn sie keine anderen schritte erfinden
wie sie das ausgleichen das dann
wirklich eine eine größere wende für die
ukraine eintreten könnte als sie jetzt
erfolgt dh die frage von einem user
namens harvard o welche seite wird durch
den winter am meisten gestoppt oder
eingeschränkt russland oder die ukraine
haben sie jetzt beantwortet mit russland
wird am meisten gestoppt rein
militärisch russland politisch und das
ist natürlich der grund warum putin
jetzt nicht nach waffenstillstand oder
noch verhandlungen sehen will politisch
gibt es natürlich eine ganze reihe von
entscheidungen die auch zu ungunsten der
ukraine ausgehen können eines ist die
midterm elections wo natürlich die angst
vor einem großen amerikanischen sieg der
innenpolitische probleme für präsident
beiden bereiten könnte groß ist das
zweite ist natürlich die gaskrise in
europa und wie sich europa dann verhält
all das noch unsicherheiten westlicher
nachschub an munition an waffen ist für
die ukraine enorm wichtig gerade
natürlich aus den usa die eindeutig
größter lieferant sind dass sie
natürlich unwägbarkeiten dialog
rheinischer sicht so jetzt mal nicht
abschätzbar sind aber rein militärisch
ist es für die wird es wenn sozusagen
die politischen rahmenbedingungen
dieselben bleiben dann spricht der
winter eher für die ukraine ist für die
russische seite dann gehen wir mal ein
auf diesen komplex westliche
waffenlieferungen ein user namens unit
schreibt über youtube bester experte hat
gräßel kommen dieses jahr noch westliche
panzer in die ukraine das ist seine
frage und dazu möchte ich ergänzen eine
äußerung von unserer
verteidigungsministerin christine
lambrecht die hatten nämlich heute bei
der kabinettsklausur in meseberg
folgendes gesagt zitat ich muss zugeben
als verteidigungsministerin da kommen
wir an die grenzen dessen was wir aus
der bundeswehr abgeben können
ja
dass die bundeswehr jetzt nicht in der
besten lage ist großartig gepanzerte
fahrzeuge abzugeben das möchte ich gar
nicht bestreiten aber man kann natürlich
über das eine oder andere fahrzeug das
bald ausgeschieden wird etwa im bereich
der mader diskutieren oder
transportpanzer fuchs der durch den
boxer abgelöst wird
aber das sind keine großen bestände
das macht das sozusagen das kraut nicht
ganz besonders fett war es natürlich
deutscher seite das kraut fett machen
würde das sinn altbestände die
im bereich der rüstungsindustrie sind
hier gibt es ja zum beispiel auch
leopard 2 die leber 24 hauptsächlich
also ältere varianten dieses
kampfpanzers die
ausgeschieden wurden in verschiedenen
streitkräften in europa auch in der
bundeswehr die jetzt wieder das material
reserve an die hersteller zurück
gegangen sind um dort entweder
modernisiert zu werden oder etwas
basisfahrzeug für umrüstungen dienen und
da gibt es schon größere bestände die
wirklich einen unterschied machen würden
da gibt es intensive diskussionen
innerhalb der nato bzw unter den
unterstützung staaten der ukraine ob die
geliefert werden sollen oder nicht der
kanzler hat hier eine sehr skeptische
meinung dazu ich sehe auch bei vielen
alliierten staaten dass diese
ursprünglich geteilte skeptische meinung
sich mittlerweile ins gegenteil war
0-prinzip dass die ukraine mit dem
geliebten mit den gelieferten waffen
recht gut umgehen können dass die
ausbildungszeiten nicht so die
horrorvorstellung sind wie man das am
anfang des krieges gedacht hat oder
hätte und der spanische vorstoß etwa
leopard zu älterer bau serien als auch
eben lieber 24 zu liefern
der derzeit schon dass man hier immer
weiter in diese richtung denkt in dem
sinn würde ich es nicht ausschließen
obwohl ich natürlich
natürlich zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt
nichts sagen kann da gibt's schon mit
klaren sachstand ist auch so dass in
europa eigentlich der leopard-2 und vor
allen dingen die die variante leo k24
der einzige westliche kampfpanzer ist
der in größerer stückzahl geliefert
werden kann der challenger asien in den
jeweiligen ländern noch voll im einsatz
die gibt es andere worte nirgendwo in
europa da gibt es kaum reserve bestände
an diesen fahrzeugen
das bisschen was ist eine sehr begibt
die werden als ersatzteillager
gebraucht für die bestehenden bestände
das sind nennen in den listen geführten
panzern zum teil keine getriebe mehr
drin keine motoren mehr drin weil die
schon ausgeschlachtet wurden also es
gibt als funktionsfähiges gerät nur den
leopard 2 und mit geringerer zahl ein
bisschen den leopard 1 sonst gibt es in
den usa nur mehr ins panzer auch die
werden gerade fit gemacht für polen da
läuft ja ein sehr großer ringtausch
wenn der abgewickelt ist dann sind wir
aber schon 2023 dann könnten die ukraine
diese kampfbahn zu bekommen zum
abschluss noch zwei kurze fragen ein
user namens mittel über youtube möchte
wissen wann wir mehr infos kriegen aus
der ukraine in bezug auf diese groß auf
wenn sie wurde auf diese offensive und
uwe jacobs möchte gerne wissen wie lange
die offensive dauern könnte
ich schätze dass wir ende der woche sind
an festere
bisschen handfestere ukrainische angaben
bekommen davor wird das glaube ich
schwer
auch auf der russischen seite ist es so
dass sozusagen die offiziellen kanäle
jetzt rein
melden was sozusagen politisch erwünscht
ist dass es noch ein paar militär
blogger gibt die net vermelden was
sachstand ist aber auch hier versucht ja
die russische seite den
informationsstand über diese offensive
so gering wie möglich zu halten weil die
durchbrüche natürlich aus der russischen
sicht eigentlich sind das heißt ukrainer
sagen nichts und die russen sagen immer
weniger das heißt natürlich unsere
informationslage sinkt jetzt mal enorm
ende der woche würde ich sagen ist ein
guter zeitpunkt x abzuschätzen was
wirklich passiert ist
eine eine informationsquelle die man
immer nutzen kann das sind natürlich die
die nasa die amerikanische
weltraumbehörde satelliten im all die
waldbrände melden feuer in waldbrände
melden dieses satelliten die geben auch
aufschluss über andere wertige feuer
explodierende munitionsdepots zum
beispiel sind auch ein gutes feuer oder
auch natürlich starke artillerie
tätigkeit da kann man anhand dieser
bilder kann man so etwa abschätzen
grob wo die front in etwa verlaufen wo
sich die verschiebungen andeuten
beziehungsweise schon
ergeben haben und da gibt es ja auch ein
paar blogger die das sehr genau
mitverfolgen und hier karten zeichnen
das wäre mein tipp für die
interessierten das genau zu verfolgen
da lässt lassen sich dann die die besten
rückschlüsse daraus ziehen auf das
kampfgeschehen und wie lange die
offensive dauern könnte
das hängt sehr stark von den von den
erfolgen auch also sollten die russen
ihre zweite linie gut besetzen können
sollten sie ordnungsgemäß zurückfallen
dann würde ich sagen ihr
sozusagen frieren die bilder von dem was
wir an durchbrüchen haben in etwa zwei
tagen ein und dann ist die offensive die
ukraine würden natürlich noch probieren
wo es in lücken wo wo ergeben sich für
uns chancen aber dann wäre das im grunde
mit mit anfang der nächsten woche
wahrscheinlich beendet sollte das nicht
der fall sein sollten sich da noch
lücken auf zu und dann kann diese
offensive
gut und gern noch zwei wochen
weitergehen je nachdem wie lange und wie
strukturiert dann auch russische
widerstands tasche sich bilden ob es den
ukraine gelingt die russen von den von
tomtom brücken komplett abzuschneiden
beziehungen und affären beziehung oder
nicht dahin viel viel davon ab
ortskern von carson orts kämpfen können
sich sehr lange hinziehen allerdings
haben da die ukraine natürlich den
großen vorteil dass sie von der
bevölkerung
mit informationen versorgt werden dass
die bevölkerung gruppe auf ihrer seite
steht und damit natürlich auch als etwa
auf claire für für wege in den rücken
des gegners et cetera offen steht und
das könnte natürlich den ortskern person
erheblich verkürzen aber der kann sich
im extremfall auch monate hinziehen
sagt der militärexperte dr gustav größe
vielen dank dass sie mit expertise mit
ihrer expertise bei uns in der sendung
waren vielen dank für die beantwortung
der vielen vielen fragen und sie haben
gerade das stichwort interessierte
genannt wir hatten wahnsinnig viele
interessierte zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer an userinnen und user innen
heute dabei also vielen dank auch an die
community fürs mitmachen und enden
möchte ich mit einem dunk von rené
mernyi der schreibt über youtube danke
liebes zdf team für diese möglichkeit
fragen zu stellen und aufklärung zu
erhalten das machen wir sehr sehr gerne
und auch gerne wieder bleiben sie uns
treu bis zum nächsten mal tschüss